- Kelly! Let's talk about
this new project girl.
It sounds amazing.
Tell us about it.
- I'm so excited actually,
cuz I didn't know when
we'd be able to like talk
about it, but apparently
I can now, so it's called
American Song Contest
and I've been talking to
the producers of The Voice
and Eurovision for a minute about it.
It's, I've been obsessed with Eurovision.
So when I went overseas
like years ago, you know
after winning Idol, I, I
noticed, like there was
this huge competition.
I'd never heard of it before
and it's called Eurovision,
and it was amazing.
And I thought it was so cool
cause all the territories get represented.
So they're finally bringing
it over to the states
and it's called American
Song Contest - ASC.
And it's really cool because I feel like
I think everybody could agree,
We're pretty divided like as
a nation and it's really cool
cause all 50 states
there's five U.S.
territories and then, um, DC,
our nation's capital,
everybody gets represented.
So like there's a person
representing every state
every part and they all
enter in this competition.
And the cool thing about it
too is that it's original songs
and as a songwriter, I
think that's awesome.
- [Host] Oh, yes.
Cause it's like a
different, you know, like
there's a lot of shows
out there, you know,
that have competitions
with like, you know,
singing or artists or whatever.
And it's really cool cause
it's the best song wins out.
And I'm hosting, I'm
co-hosting with Snoop Dogg
- Hey!
(Host and audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Which, we got to
work together on The Voice.
- I love it!
- I know, I was so excited.
[Kelly] We got to work
together on The Voice
It was so fun.
- [Host] Yeah, he's great, he's great.
You know, I know him from
baby boy, years, years ago
but he's still a really
dear friend of mine.
He's incredible. You're
gonna have a good time.
That's not even gonna be work.
(laughs)
- Oh my God, No.
That's why I was like, they,
they asked me and I'm like
first of all, I'm like such a nerd
I'm so excited about the show.
So all right, I'll do that.
And it was just exciting
cause I liked working with Snoop Dogg.
So that was, I'd already
worked with him, so
that, I think that'll be really cool too.
I'm, this is probably gonna be
what I'm gonna wear for that too, so.
- That's good. It's it's all
good, you'll be beautiful.
- Keeping it real all the time.